jo koy you're not gonna believe this I
found Bonnie McFarlane is officially an
hour and it's not even late yes right
cancel thank God for you that's
disrespectful
it is you wouldn't disrespect us like no
now we're not sure six minutes early
body what makes you think they just do I
mean that's disrespect an hour and six
minutes when you come in an hour and six
minutes late you don't smile now with a
story yeah yeah yes something sad
happened yeah why are you so late
I so lean I honestly thought I thought I
was just six minutes late no no you're
66 minutes late yeah so Barney you're
actually two times late because yo seven
yeah
how come you thought you were an hour
late was it a miscommunication or was it
I saw on Twitter people were like where
are you then I went back and looked at
the text and I was like oh [ __ ] okay we
were gonna get rolling but it's your
fault you should still get rolling you
know I mean well this was not on him the
whole hour and for you welcome to the
show eight o'clock you know that's what
you mean like you just like a small
child
yeah those comedians would just small
children aren't we though that's good
I'm glad you went deep to start wait you
can't come in without it believe that is
good misdirection what are you a
magician
you got here early now yeah you guys are
lucky to have me yeah I do appreciate
you guys having me on I like the
attitude it's our place I like that I
really do I you know mr. Lee [ __ ] but
right I like that you guys had me okay
well I'm glad that you're both here I
mean last time jo koy would did the show
that was in Montreal yeah and you ended
up with getting into a fight with Bobby
Bigelow fine you wanted to call him Bob
and he was like you can't
oh you mean Robert it's a little surly
yeah yeah yeah yeah that was fun that
was the best 10 minutes of my life yeah
yeah kind of show people like there's
somebody behind the scene like a request
line barking up it was a minor
disagreement but it was entertaining
you show up like an hour and 10 minutes
late and then you just want us to play a
clip from an old fairy suggestion on the
show she requested some of the greatest
show money are we starting to figure out
that maybe it wasn't our fault that you
lost your radio show these are your what
Bob Kelly stand by no no we grabbed it I
would love to hear one line of that yeah
I'm sure we could find it now that it's
his idea it's a great idea why I didn't
say it was a great idea that you're
actually not a bad idea Jim little
history never hurt anybody
no yeah and the Emmy goes to with the
best selection of an old show sure
Norton that was right one cliff that's
right well welcome welcome Joe I'm so
happy here wait y-you amantha his hair
is just wrapping around from the back
incoming on your head that's right you
know that's right like a perfect
consistency
goes up top not so not not as good but
that's what you have to do as Ayub to
make a choice you either have to start
letting it grow to where you bring it
down cuz it's not gonna be up anymore or
you get the weird hair plugs and that
can end in disaster
yeah that's bad you shave yours off
before well you lose
just got rid of it no I said you know
what yes I got friends that do that yeah
full head of hair and they shave it
they'd rather be bald
I've kept my hair very very short and
I've had a full hair it's gets thinned a
little bit but I did this long before
its end right I just like it I've telex
- it's [ __ ] horrible my hair when I
have hair stinks do you look like [ __ ]
when you have hair I do I'm sorry to
hear that man you're as handsome as
you've ever been
it's not really yeah I appreciate that
nicely you could take it as a compliment
yeah yeah yeah she would never insult me
both bald sees me yeah
bald seems like an easy lifestyle is
just good yeah it's so good but you have
to I mean your husband has a full head a
good has more the voice has a good he's
a good head of hair he's a good hair
doesn't grow on a busy street no I've
heard you have a plump ass how come you
can't take more of this I swear to God
doesn't grow on a busy street I didn't
get asses don't grow I apologize I
totally miss really thought she said
that what about anal sex is a busy
street I'm ready for some anal right I
went with it I think what Barney was
trying to say was because rich is stupid
he has a full head of hair was that yeah
that no I understand okay you get you
you get metaphors I do I do with your
right Jim if she had said ass doesn't
grow that would have been a problem I
just I what had I not known that you
misheard me I still thought it was a
funny mislead thing to decide couldn't
take credit for it like I meant it to be
there well with that no no honesty is
the key is you ever do that
you do a joke and the audience laughs
really loud and then you do the tag and
they realize what you meant and they
stop laughing you know you're like oh
they thought something completely
different also like your misdirect just
completely doesn't work well like I
think I'm making a joke about something
they're miss reading it laughing really
hard then you do the tag you clear
everything up for everybody and then
they're like oh no and Trump is stupid
they laugh do you tag it with don't you
hate the Jews can I take back the laughs
from before yeah and realize it's a bad
tag sometimes a bad tag will ruin it
yeah meaning like the joke itself works
then you just get greedy right I've
gotten greedy many times done like off
and he'd feel the steam coming just the
energy drain yeah yeah tag you get
halfway and you're like I know TV
trickling hey alive at the improv or a
clever tag and like they kind of
believed that there was a live moment
happening and then your tag just wrecks
it yeah yeah oh it was written so you
feel that like as you're doing the tag
you're going oh no I have much less gas
than I thought I feel like this rain
yeah the air comes out of the balloon
right I should have left him wanting
more and there's no place for me to go
now
don't worry assume you're asking all the
right questions and you still won't
learn anything about comedy comedy you
gotta study it you got to go on every
night I applied to put trapped by chess
the 10,000 hours I've tried to learn
chess and play a grandmaster there was
we're not 10,000 I've always the guy
wants to do every task does nobody know
I'm talking about no I know 10,000 hours
I mean first 10,000 hours was Malcolm
Gladwell said well he he co-opted it he
didn't he didn't he didn't originate
that I probably already did it you know
he's right no I don't think so I think
everybody gives him credit for and it
wasn't him it was a Middle Eastern
scholar no I don't know who but he
writes these books there's all kinds of
references in the back it's all like he
cites these things he popularized well
he doesn't know if he actually did that
or not he's just saying he might have I
know and I'm I'm giving him credit for
saying I might yeah credit for being on
the fence I even how's your podcast
well it's good man it's really good man
that we that turned real quick I'd like
to ask you yeah man it's been great
right you man
now the ask wrong thing actually starts
to make sense you like okay this is just
bunnies oh yeah they wouldn't have had
you but I did it while I was on serious
it was with radio shows oh yeah yeah oh
that was the podcaster I love their
shabi that shows [ __ ] is phenomenal
right it's very funny you talking about
my wife hates me uh-huh
and what's the name of jokeboys prices
koi pond koi pond yeah no one likes me
I'm an [ __ ]
no you because you're perceptive about
how people feel about you that's what
yeah Bonnie's main strength is her
self-awareness yeah I know it's like as
soon as I start talking I got an eye I'm
annoyed with myself right Yeah right I
get that
no Stan you're so used to you you're a
nice guy Joe yeah I'm a nice guy nice to
people yeah when the venom comes out the
venom comes out we find the Bobby
clippings right here we have the moment
yeah yeah yeah I will say that yeah I've
always known joy to Joe to be like a
nice guy very uh very a nice mellow dude
oh geez dude Chelsea Lately there's
always a good guy to be on panel with
just a funny guy and I'm a lot of times
when I see like a nice guy comedian I go
this is strange because all the
comedian's that I know are just
miserable and saying awful things about
each other just to you you should say
they're they're miserable
to me laugh and trade jokes that needed
a citation
miss Irwin by ourselves it's all good
times we help each other with our acts
on TV shows that really help my god yeah
yeah yeah like I'll bounce the joke off
Joe knows any money try this the Hilton
want to hear we break out our notebooks
and create the comedy greenroom is just
a magic really great place of helping
sharing but it's moments like this when
you go oh that's right Joe is just
trying to be a nice guy but the moment
confrontation rears its ugly head he's
been waiting for this for time call you
Bobby my whole time I've known you it's
[ __ ] Robert your dick call me Bobby
any time you want you [ __ ] weirdo
weirdo my name is Joe I tell everyone to
call me [ __ ] Joe Joe came in a little
salty but Bob really hit back hard with
and with real anger can I just say Bobby
or Robert he was being aggressive but
positive towards you he was like call me
whatever the [ __ ] you want yeah yeah but
then he called him a [ __ ] weirdo yeah
[ __ ] it with you turn the light switch
on man you know me let's go right right
and he started also leaning in the body
Joe did call him a dick first but it was
like the way come on you dick when can I
call you that's just like Bros being
Bros yeah it's like everyone he says
it's like it'll be a group of us and
like everyone's calling them Bobby and
it's like ya know and Robert to you yeah
I know Robert right yeah I've got very
salty back well let's see all right
yeah Bobby Robert Bobby yo Bobby [ __ ]
go by Bobby [ __ ] over here Jerry
Norton dick is this within the first
like two minutes yes this is Bobby
listen we're here I know you're gonna
start yelling at me any second child
legs and those dumb shorts call me this
call me that call me this call me that
and you're the one who's like Bonnie
Howard six minutes late that's a good
let's just remember that he will pick up
on weaknesses though he's like you can't
come back from that Bonnie so you're
trying to point out something in the
argument and he's like [ __ ] you yeah
we're late an hour and six minutes is a
tremendous amount that's a lot of you
tonight show you would have missed the
entire show thank you guys I had fun on
town yeah you can compliment yourself a
bit guys you know the the gal from do
you want to finish this no with the gal
from where from Mesa amazing yeah Alex
Borstein is that who it is Alex Borstein
from Antietam she's on no no the one
that plays the comedian the comedian on
the show she didn't have it she didn't
seem that excited to meet me which I
thought was weird I thought she'd be
like wow why well Sam listen I'll
explain it like that who is the guy who
played spider-man he was on the show
Garfield that was Andrew Garfield
however Tobey Maguire
in the earlier film build was on the
show and let's say that he after talking
to Jimmy came backstage and the real
spider-man was there you think he's
gonna be like no not right now
it's gonna meet the real [ __ ]
spider-man I see so you're saying since
I'm a lady comic you should be bowing
down to me right now
what's your portray yes let me get in
here and [ __ ] find out everything I
can find out did you pick your brain for
tips he took a quick photo
I mean she's that they already I mean
they're doing tremendously well I don't
think she's at the point now where she's
like I need she's past character study
yeah I mean were you there or were you a
little late six minutes late oh I
thought I just had to be here when the
show started no my bad Jimmy I thought
you said Ted I went into her dressing
room and it was huge
the person playing a comedian gets a
huge dressing room the real deal right
well yeah but the person playing the
comedian is like super popular like jo
koy is a comedian right I've heard that
he probably gets the big dresser
he's a wordplay comedian of the year yes
[Laughter]
shut up let's go back to uh should we go
back to the neymar yes or look it seems
like it's bringing it on Weston
everybody cuz I look like the after shot
of a workout video
I will always remember pros do Joe being
a professional in defusing the tensions
in my head I already know I'm winning
okay so you're gonna live and I enjoy
homosexual I don't appreciate but I mean
it's not slanderous is it you know
slanders means he's lying perfect though
you could show this to a class a
university or something I'm Canadian
College and you know this is like this
is how interaction should go you get mad
then somebody says something funny then
you come around you know that's like
comics they can switch they can turn on
a dime
you did lose and then everybody's happy
but them coming around is usually just a
technique while we're thinking yeah like
literally like you know I think of the
audience when you're like oh yeah you
guys were a great crowd no one says that
unless we're thinking of something out
of all the shows this was the best one
right yeah you don't read in front of an
audience that you're like these guys are
great I got a compliment these guys I
have but it's usually a technique it's
usually something you're pausing and
your mind you're the one part your brain
is going and use your mouth is opening
and that garbage is flying out of it
just to keep them calm for a second so
you play like huge rooms new techniques
can you do in in rooms like that or do
you not even need techniques no I still
play it like a club you know what I mean
like I always want to change it cuz you
got a lot of people that are coming a
lot you know I mean a lot of regulars
really feeding travelling to see me you
see yeah yeah so it's like I got to
change it up I really do it it's like it
it does matter it's 2,000 or whatever
it's like I see the one person in the
front row say [ __ ] I got to change it so
they're trans me they're following you
like like
yeah yeah I got a few like that that
come you know especially if I'm on the
East Coast side a little swing really
love wordplay and I'm sorry with it
I forgot that if you were here earlier
passive-aggressiveness building between
you're late and YouTube wordplay stuff
just keeps the generate it's a hacking
country okay and you're or don't talk
[Laughter]
shut the [ __ ] up
a lot of small talk such little words
coming out of that [ __ ] mouth that's
another word play by the way the
audience is a lot smarter right that was
but that is wordplay - yeah yeah koi
pond is wordplay you got you what are
you doing the koi pond is it just what
we're doing here right yeah is that what
it is [ __ ] it yeah I got my guy chased
through so he's really funny man he goes
on the road with me it's a lot of fun
man I have so much fun on it I enjoy it
yeah it was in Corolla studio yeah I
love it man you crazy when they started
coming around like oh [ __ ] there's the
you really I was in Malaysia and they're
like oh we love you on the koi pond
that's what we listen I'm like what the
[ __ ] I didn't think he got outside of LA
right all right cool thanks I had no
idea there was a reach like that you
just started to start it and then you
realize like I'm opening up new
audiences yeah doing this yeah Adams the
one that told me he's like he'll just do
it and he produces it and I'm just like
okay I didn't think anything of it and I
was like wow this is thing this thing's
really reaching people yeah yeah it is
weird when you do it all the sudden you
realize that people you're doing a
podcast
people like wow they'd rather go see
that than the real person
yeah let's no that's crazy or they just
say well to show Jim Jim's having you
know Jim has a podcast other than this
radio show oh there's another one
what's the chip chip or some podcast and
took itself faster for that than they do
for myself [ __ ] out Jim Jim person is
becoming really popular humiliated
coming it is but it's man millions at
the expense of Jim Norton like people
aren't going to seesaw there's not in
the end wise people are picking like I'm
a Jim Norton fan so I like chip to
they're like no I'm gonna go with chip
yeah unfortunately and it seems like
yeah and it's not if not a seesaw in the
traditional sense because a seesaw it
goes back and forth I give a big fat
person was on one end of a seesaw and
like yeah a little handsome rob was on
the other end it just stays waited
November I'm never going back
alright so uh this the end of the
argument with Joe and not go back to no
I just realized that I'm bringing it
back to the name thing yeah when we move
it doesn't seem constructive I apologize
for doing that now I you're okay with
that yeah I'm okay that's great
what does this think you're hosting
tonight bar what is secret handshake oh
that's a show we do every first
Wednesday of every month the stress
factory in New Jersey it's a fun show
it's gonna be Mike Vecchio and tonight
and others I'm no know what why is it
called secret handshake I don't know
really I mean I've been telling people
something but it's not really true what
have you been saying cuz cuz alley man
came up with the name and I just was
like that's a good name so let's let's
do it but I say it's cuz I can secret
handshake in some big X to come out
there but
are you doing awful explanation yeah
I got my secret handshake and get some
people out there
yeah who are some of the people that
you've gotten through your show the big
act chipper chip chip chip chip chip
person who begotten Richard Vash that's
cool and my wife hates means of course
the podcast is that going gangbusters I
don't know I don't keep track of that
[ __ ] I have to do it once a week I
[ __ ] do it you still don't like it I
mean I would be I like doing podcasts I
like doing radio it was there something
about is it rich yeah but I was doing a
podcast yesterday and then they were
like thanks to the fans and you know
they were naming certain people we love
the the memes you send out you know they
were really being specific and I was
like oh my god we do none of this
we're not like why are you listening
well they're building a community you
just you you stay in a hole of
self-deprecation like I've never doesn't
help no no of course not what my my
podcast has no reach no and if
somebody's told me they're from Malaysia
listening I'd be like what are you doing
with your life
Shane listened to us and listened to ya
which I mean I order than the koi pond
he's he's putting something out that
he's proud of right he likes it which
brand new it's always a little
embarrassed to be honest it's a newish
podcast right my wife hates me is it no
it's like no I didn't realize
I guess you work anymore Jim no I just
sit back well ya know I didn't realize
that you would take doing a podcast for
six years literally as its brand new so
that's a good point yeah even I don't
use the word brand I think you said is
it new til six years is money you were
late you know six year long do you say
how old is your baby
no sold your kid right that's the my
credit Yeah right right oh so okay so ya
know we have a kid
the child is that way your daughter no
I'm for the podcast our podcast is six
or seven years old
guess who's started going to school and
I'm saying the podcast is not a new
podcast it's an old podcast yeah I guess
you're right it's been around for a long
time
sure when you look at the pocket I don't
know what a long podcast is it's been
around for about seven years
yeah well when you're in a 13-year
marriage it's you know it's half of that
right yeah it's long it's a long time
especially with floss yeah I would
imagine that it grates on you at times
um I'm I think I'm doing a good job you
know I'm I'm hanging in hey did you do a
great did you just talk cover for your
book or do you only have a hard copy
no soft just you add it to that or no
what do you mean did you put a new
material for the soft cover no no I
didn't do a hard cut adjusted soft oh
sorry yeah yeah yeah you didn't do hard
cover that soft okay is this all passive
aggressive insults towards me I'm on
door opening anymore I was late I
apologize was it in some time you were
close yeah everything I've talked to you
since Matthew were named died yeah he
did your book you were developing
something with him or is it just a book
just a book yeah no I wasn't developing
anything with him
why did rich say that no no no rich just
starts putting that rich is like we
can't get Bourdain to go to pitches so
obviously so what if we just say that we
were TiVo yeah yeah we were already at
something in the works but what can you
do and you know but if you guys want to
pick that up okay good idea
I did notice on the the video Sam the
beard is [ __ ] amazing
thank you very you like it see we hate
it do use we are these Rob hates it I
hated Troy - Rob yeah it's okay hates it
Anthony hates it
we all hate it you hate it yeah of
course I do holy SH I think he's just
joined in the crew he's got a [ __ ]
shitty beard on his face yes
Jim as the entire staff paralyzed by
fear power and that's very clear when
you look around this room they're all
nervous they're sweating yeah it was
very messy
no one likes us man Jimmy your life is
messy it's a decision but I'm not but I
don't get everyone to say it's good they
all know if you ask what anybody like my
lifestyle they don't go no what do you
think it was live Troy I think it's cool
[Laughter]
Troy hope choices they're going like I
don't know at this point in my life if I
should still be then he goes well Jim
still rockin and rollin yeah he's doing
awesome so yeah I don't think that
everybody thinks that your life is bad I
say keep the beard man I'm going today I
keep it yeah mmm more and more flannels
and a [ __ ] axe by that time slowly
I'm adding things to me to make to
convince people that there are masculine
traits Yeah right like oh yeah you're
very [ __ ] waif-like and twinkers
right but nobody remembers as I say it
look like the brawny paper towel guy
yeah toho the brawny brawny paper yeah
yeah yeah I didn't mess that up I think
it had the Burnie paper towel guy you
look more masculine sure I guess I think
it sure maybe at one point he had a
beard maybe not every woman wanted to
[ __ ] the brawny towel guy that's exactly
it
Bonnie I wanted to [ __ ] his brains Oh
God nobody's seen as this masculine the
brawny towel guy everybody knows what
this is a brawny towel guy is masculine
Bonnie did you go through a period of
time where you wanted to [ __ ] the paper
towel guy I know every guy wanted to get
jerked off by Madge when we saw him
putting people Stan's in the liquid and
we all want every woman wanted to [ __ ]
the Barney guy's [ __ ] yeah I remember
that all right yeah
body did you ever go through a period of
your life where you wanted to eat the
brawny paper towel guy's [ __ ] yes all
right I see corrected maybe maybe that
is right Travis you wanted to [ __ ] the
brawny paper towel guy who didn't yeah
okay on the Left done that one look look
at him he's all handsome with his no no
no
top-1 let's see that's the one I
remember when I was a kid with this
Mustang that's the guy women wanted to
have sex matter they do see the yeah
that's why they'd buy the [ __ ] towel
so wonder whether the role was the PAS
empty they can [ __ ] himself in this
image ripped up plastic label on here
they go through the towels quickly just
to get to that tube to [ __ ] himself
it's a drawing
yeah it's that's why that's what they
use the paper towels for it's a real
[ __ ] panty moistener just stop up
their panties with the paper towel I can
stop up the panties I don't know if your
understanding of females is on point
probably not yeah I don't not a hundred
percent on that what happens is the
vaginas get very wet yeah and write
paper towels to SAP it up we need to
sell this it gets the reaction we feed
women sobbing they're outdoors leave
that outdoorsy there in the [ __ ]
trees yes woods behind him he's a man
doing man [ __ ] that has nothing to do
with kitchen yeah yeah [ __ ] these guys
don't use paper towels oh maybe they're
saying these are the trees we cut down
to make these paper towels that you're
just gonna throw them all out anyway
yeah that is definitely your shirt
though sale thank you yeah thank you
yeah I mean you know it looks good I
think it's important I think you got to
remind people of your masculinity
sometimes especially if you're Sam
Roberts it's something you have to
constantly remind people yeah I don't
disagree you might Bend um your Twinkie
Sh I am so you want your on Adams
Network yeah he's a [ __ ] machine
Corolla yeah man machine there is a
machine man five shows a week
[ __ ] four shows a week whatever it is
which is like a radio show he left radio
and immediately went into podcasting and
did it the audience would have the same
content
yeah that they could just go right to
knocks it out his arm he's strong too
[ __ ] yeah he's a lot of people as soon
as show him but he literally she's like
a one-hour radio show it's perfect it's
perfect only I mean you do one hour it's
easy just go in knock it out
yeah I mean commercial reads and like
regular segments and bits random just
talks a lot that he's a very good talker
he's like
he's a really good he doesn't even need
anybody there he's just a good explainer
easiest he's a great great talker he's a
lot of interest he's obsessed with
that's what makes him easy just go a
little bit yeah oh yeah but I it was
like his use talk he wants about
repairing a lawn chair yeah he talked
about it for 15 minutes but it was
pretty interesting and the fact that he
could keep you interested for that long
I was like yeah I mean he's really good
at this yeah I'd watch history and
that's what makes him good that Sh I
mean that's his superpower yeah you know
he's using what he was given by God to
do good I could never be interesting
about that for more than 30 seconds if
that I couldn't give you that maybe I
was just counting a little compliment
for myself yeah talking about this this
is the most boring topic that he talked
about was a fence and the guy made the
fence in my yard
and it was crooked right but he was like
no it's not crooked because it's going
with with the land with the land yeah he
goes it's straight like and he put the
thing on there and then and then Adam
just went off on it 15 minutes yeah
because he's like no you [ __ ] idiot
it's not straight like like that's
that's not straight right level says
it's straight but it's not [ __ ]
straight if you look at it and it's
crooked then it's [ __ ] crooked right
like build it to your site when you
stand back and you see something that's
a straight line that's straight and
you're going just because it's measured
everything you just listen to everything
that's just what the [ __ ] in the level
said it's straight so it must be
straight and I was sitting there with my
mouth oh because I was like yeah this is
what I wanted to [ __ ] say this guy
right he wasn't listening to me but I
already paid for the [ __ ] fence so
now it's like crooked when it's coming
down the stairs and he even pulled out
the low and because he's saying it you
start to get even more passionate about
it man because he was right yeah told
Adam about is that yeah he [ __ ]
people I hate it when they [ __ ] do
that like the house does even sit
straight everyone thinks the house is
level it's not right like it's [ __ ]
crooked like the walls for your [ __ ]
TV's crooked it's gotta be crooked you
want it [ __ ] straight look at it and
go is that straight but that's
Asperger's when you're like if I'm
looking at
and it straight it's straight and he's
the ones like no it's not straight try
to make sure that it's over here I got
to put my level up exactly like for most
of us it's straight it's fine yeah we're
gonna we don't need to get all crazy
about this it's like nobody everybody
comes over they look at the fence they
don't say it's crooked you're fine
absolutely who the hell needs to sit at
home one or something straight he does
just shouting at you did you vote
yesterday Bonnie I'm gonna do it
tomorrow I can't vote I'm a pedophile no
I United citizen or whatever no I'm a
legal alien Oh
so you're one of those caravan people
they keep talking about that's tough
that's I've been there for a while then
I said let me get a flight I'm gonna see
who won I'll go for them yeah you try to
stay away from politics mostly though
you like to keep it to myself
right get that big broad audience yeah
my sister my dad go in and out you know
they never they butt heads like this
conversations [ __ ] boring yeah I
don't wanna hear it I can't just I'm
good right I paid my taxes I'm good
right yeah but things haven't been
bothering you lately I don't want to
talk about it well hey Bonnie you're
supposed to be like a feminist woman who
supports women what does that mean is he
woman no I mean I would just think that
you were more I know you can't vote but
did you were you encouraging other
people to vote no that was one thing
that that [ __ ] irritates me yeah
celebrities signalling with the voting
is right all right I am a I'm a grown
woman I know where am i voting [ __ ]
stations find out you can go to this
website and put in your zip code I don't
understand the people who get up every
day they see 40 tweets about go vote and
they're like you know what I better
start telling people to vote well yours
out [ __ ] clothing store it's like
don't forget to vote it's like stay out
of it call some people like they get it
they get likes on it oh thank you for
telling people to vote it's good that
you tell people do but that's
because it's like then I'm doing
something I'm doing something I'm liking
somebody else's post about voting now
they've got 4000 likes on it now they
feel like they've done something right I
didn't vote but I liked that person's I
voted sticker so it's it's close its
close enough most people who came in
with the I voted sticker so yeah it's
not an accomplishment it's just a thing
you just go and do it's like that's
baseline you're allowed to go do this if
you want to cool it so like you know the
whole like blue no matter who and stuff
you know it's what's the difference
between like if you're just gonna be
blind to one side if you're you yeah I
mean obviously I'm not the first person
but it's like you're saying like vote
unless you're a Republican oh yeah
well that they were saying they were
like you know the Democrats they we need
to bring everybody together
no more separating people let's bring
everybody together well in order to do
that obviously there are other people
right no no no no we could bring
everybody together if you just think
like me that way right we've all got to
start coming to a common ground on my
side right that's possible right I think
I think we'd all we don't just be more
peaceful that way I mean I there's
things that you know bother me obviously
kids in cages right the kids in cages is
you know especially when you phrase it
like that I put my kid in a cage for two
days the the she's still psychologically
damaged like do you read that like there
people are like so doing stuff like that
to prove like how psychologic like why
are you doing that to your kid yeah
definitely bad yeah although Kimmel had
Borat on his show last night we were
watching something that's very early
it's very funny but at one point that we
didn't watch on the air
he went door to door you know to talk to
people about voting and he was talking
about you know Borat thinks you know
putting Mexican kids in cages is a good
thing obviously cuz Borat but he was
able to talk to a woman who's also great
but he agreed and said that the cages
were actually better than what they had
at home sure she's
Trump was giving them three meals a day
just like his own kids that's right
it's like it's have we completely lost
like any kind of empathy to other
people's plate well I also think that
you're thinking of cages like if you
were in a cage you'd have to be crunched
over and being separated even the cage
is less appalling to me than being
separated from a child being separated
from its parent these kids don't we live
in a gilded cage though and show us like
celebrities can feel the same her sure
that these children feel I get what
they're going through
if occasion can sing why can't a caged
child poetic metaphors that make no
sense just a guy trying to relate I wish
you start tweeting like that yeah look
that's what your tweet should be just
trying to do celebrity tweets yeah yeah
but that's I mean Plus adults in a cage
is gonna be tougher because they're
short kids are short there'll be more
comfortable in the cage I think on that
level it's okay if they cried you just
rattle it you're shut up I put a cage in
my kid's room just left it open and
guess what she slept in there hard to be
separated from your daughter be hard it
would be torture absolute torture in
another country I can't even imagine
honestly it's it's just II wonder if she
was scared
um oh yeah I mean that's the thing you'd
be you don't know what's going on
my dog is crate trained though and the
dog loves up and so we'll leave the
house and the dog will go up in the cage
mm-hmm and she'll be super happy mm-hmm
great comparison you know it might be
some of these kids run to the cage yeah
like I have a kid to get used to once
they get the treats
there's no stop where are all the toys
yeah hey in there hey there's ice cream
in the cage oh boy [ __ ] out of here
three hots and a cot you lock the cage
up
refrigerator [ __ ] cage shut up rattle
rattle rattle with the metal cup right
but they're not doing the cage stuff
anymore are they they stop I think he's
just separating kids they plan to
separate the kids again with this were
they doing it too part of this they said
they were doing at least because of
human trafficking and some people are
bringing kids that weren't theirs I
don't believe that I I think that the
guy from the head of ice was saying that
you know it's his justification was is
that if you break the law you get
separated from your kids you go to jail
and you get separated from your kids so
that's what they're doing what should
they do with them though if they break
them all back together well the thing is
are they breaking I thought you were
allowed to come here if you needed with
the asylum asylum yeah but you gotta you
gotta apply for asylum
well there's a problem at the border to
where they've applied and then they're
waiting waiting waiting weeks and weeks
and weeks and it's it's a different
system than it was as far as I know I
don't know everything about it obviously
but just let's not
can we just as a people no separate kids
from but you have this caravan of people
what are you doing future sorry what do
you do if you're uh if you go out and
rob a bank and you got your kid in
that's what I know the law watch dog day
afternoon and get back to me Jimmy kids
they can't find the kids so many exactly
but there's some bunch of bad kids who
don't know how to listen get back to the
cage yeah I mean I get both side I get
what you're saying yeah yeah get back
there yeah I mean you know it's it's
tough to do it the caravan know with all
the people coming over did they say
they're gonna separate it sounds fun
doesn't it it doesn't but they're 1200
mile walk I mean unbelievable yeah your
life has to be to sneak into Mexico how
many kids are really gonna be with those
people that kids can't walk 800 miles
I'm it's there's no way there'll be like
15 people that show up here by the time
it's all done it's like a you know it's
it's it's really it's a it's so sad and
tragic and I hope that I hope that we
can have some empathy for these people
I'm not gonna cry
well then you should have voted Bonnie I
know I should've let your voice be heard
yeah so putzing around in here hi every
tower yeah it's uh I don't feel bad I
didn't photos I didn't care that much
right about what anything just who is
what about LGBT rights I care about
those why's that thing I I don't like to
see anybody mistreated oh I see I see
especially you're dating them wow you
know right and working with them Travis
um yeah I don't know you just read these
statistics about people who don't vote
yeah and it seems and you're like how
could this many people not be voting but
then if you're part of the statistic
that's not voting it seems like gross
you know what I mean it seems like a
part of the problem should you vote yeah
yeah
how do you get a sticker though so but
then we don't know exactly so you're a
[ __ ] liar with the stick on your
cheek yeah I was gonna put it on my
thumb I put it on your fist I don't know
yeah I was gonna stick it on one finger
and then put the other finger up and
that makes a peace sign yeah cuz I voted
for peace yeah but no sticker so I don't
even know if we count it yeah yeah it's
the summer beside Ernie I don't even
think there's like a receipt you don't
have it I don't have the receipt no one
holds the receipt up and shows everybody
look what I did
yeah look with me yeah what a fine
citizen right well isn't there something
like believe all men have to just
believe them that he absolutely thank
you thank you should be that way I'm
glad you brought that up
yes